yeah welcome to this video playing bingo
bongo from from Germany and I'm not
quite sure if I know hit the sky let's
check this high from cologne feeder
Messiah could be everybody and I know
cologne as I got a couple of hidden
masters probably hmm so how to continue
can you play okay I'm in the mood for
some experimental moves maybe maybe try
try to do that want to disturb disturb
his his plane yeah I know it looks
rather naive but he needs to play some
awkward moves now to to bury that no i
don't know maybe not default coming
oh maybe 2694 something like this
uh-huh
so should I just exchange on he's not
exactly threatening to take on this move
avoiding the Queen trade and intending
to harass him with 94 95 if he takes on
c5 I have a nice control over the dark
squares it's not really something to to
fear and maybe I can play 97 now and at
f5 uh-huh maybe d for now is it's a real
idea wait a moment 95 where's he going
okay sometimes this weird play can get
it too quick wins then move win of the
Queen quite nice could have done that
before you know okay yeah before he had
Queenie to retreat but now the queen is
a sweetie trap she has no no way to move
it he can play a guy must play very
Queenie two or something and then not
much is happening now okay okay it's
always fun to to go for scholars mate
but um yeah you should play Knight f3
simply it should be should be okay I
thought this may be tending 94 so it's
not clear that it's so terrible for
black I can what so maybe play this he
has made many pornos so maybe not great
but it was were to try probably yeah
thanks for watching